the Joe Rogan experience by her that
Greta Thornburg girl the climate girl
who yelled at everybody she's Person of
the Year at Time magazine let's go Oh is
everybody losing their [ __ ] mind
I think so she's um wasn't she on a
strike
look obviously climate change is a real
thing climate change is a real important
thing just get that other way for any
was it I'm saying is what is she 14 15
no no by complaining on television it
doesn't make you the most important
person of the year or the most impactful
person here you just got lucky that
right around the time where they were
making this list you did that thing
they're like let's pick Greta let's pick
Greta little trigger trunk Oh Trump will
get triggered you know and apparently
Donald Trump jr. did get triggered they
tweeted about it but yeah but this is a
[ __ ] if this was four months from now
you would completely forget her there'd
be some new thing see she she caught
this wave I mean did she have a good
little speech there yes it was a it made
an impact you know how many trees had to
get cut down and make all those time
magazines that there are a lot a lot of
trees how to die for that time magazine
by the way that all could be avoided
with hemp far superior paper way easier
and that's what got the whole marijuana
the legalization process started in the
first place was William Randolph Hearst
and his [ __ ] newspaper company he
didn't want to convert over to hemp
paper it's literally what started it
these [ __ ] Oh
Greta yeah Greta with her horrible tree
paper she should be ashamed of herself
that she let Time magazine chop down on
all those trees yeah just to give her
something to frame on her wall mm-hmm
right I mean come on Person of the Year
it's probably gonna drive her around I'm
just gonna be [ __ ] polluting here I'm
gonna drive around fly around how much
extra carbon would be a million to our
atmosphere because she won Woman of the
Year or person the air kid of the year
yeah this human of the year what is it
Person of the Year it's so non
gender-specific
how many women have won it let's guess
how many women have won time magazine
person here do you know Trump as a fake
person of the year framed in his in his
house I think I think I've seen that
[Applause]